- I will say, I have sat down
personally with Mark Zuckerberg,
I talk about this in the book.
He came to see me back
in September of 2019,
I believe it was.
I found that meeting much more interesting
because that was a face-to-face meeting
which he was really trying to
change my view about Facebook.
I mean, I think that's
why he came to see me.
This was in Washington,
in my senate office
and he came to see me and he
really tried to convince me
that Facebook should be
kind of a national champion,
that we needed Facebook
to be big and powerful
in order to take on Communist China.
Then he really went on and on about this
for quite some time.
When I turned the subject
to the question of monopoly,
he got much less
interested in conversation.
He said "Well, we're not
a monopoly, we're not."
I said, "Okay, well, if you're not,
and if you're not afraid of competition,
why don't you sell off
Instagram and WhatsApp?
I mean, you bought them
so that they wouldn't compete with you.
You didn't start them, you bought them.
Why don't you sell you?
Why don't you spin them off?"
And that made him very angry,
he was very offended by that.
He thought that that was
a ridiculous suggestion.
And I said, "Well,
that's 'cause you're
committed to your monopoly.
I mean, you don't want competition.
You wanna be able to
control the whole show,"
and that's really the
problem with these companies.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is the junior senator
from the great State of Missouri,
and the author of the new book,
"The Tyranny of Big Tech"
Senator Josh Hawley,
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks for having me.
- Senator, what are the
chances that this video
is not gonna be algorithmically
depressed by YouTube?
Do we have any chance that
anyone's gonna see this thing?
- I don't no. Well, given
my history with big tech,
maybe not, but we'll
keep our fingers crossed.
- I've got a similar
history with big tech.
So I wanna start by, I just literally
in the last five minutes,
as we sat down with you,
I saw two headlines that I thought,
okay, these are perfect
to tee up for the Senator.
So Breitbart is just reporting
in the last couple of minutes
that I'll read you the exact tweet.
Twitter is reportedly developing a feature
to make users reconsider sending messages
that its system detects as quote mean.
I suspect that will include
a lot of your stuff.
- Well, I suspect what will
happen is, well, first of all
if they actually enforced that,
wouldn't that shut down all of Twitter?
- That is for Twitter.
- I thought Twitter seems to subsist on
but of course I in practice,
I'm sure that will mean
that to conservatives and libertarians
that their tweets are all silenced
and the left can can go
on with the hate mongering
as long as they like,
that's usually how it works.
- Yeah. That pretty much is it.
And then this other one,
which it seems obvious
and I actually warned that
this was gonna be coming.
Twitter is now, so this
is from Becker News,
Twitter is now suspending users
who share Donald Trump's statements.
So as you know, Trump
launched ineffective blog,
it wasn't sort of people were
saying he was gonna come out
with this big platform,
apparently that's not it,
but he launched this
thing with just buttons
that could send stuff
to Twitter and Facebook.
Now they're actually deleting accounts
that just link to his stuff.
- Yeah, this is unbelievable
and their determination to
completely silence and erase
and cancel the former
president of the United States.
It's just shocking.
And the fact that they have
the power, the monopoly power
to do this and to get by with it
and that there's nowhere else
the former president can go.
And think about this former
president United States
had what, 78, 80 million
followers or something on Twitter
and many more on the other platforms,
and there's no alternative for him to go.
He's gotta try and create his own thing.
I mean, that tells you something
about the monopoly power
of these companies.
- So let's start right at the heart of it
because you are a
constitutional conservative
and at least as far as I know,
we're still governed by the constitution,
although I'm not quite sure these days,
but I know that a lot of
people, every time you say,
"Okay, we've got to do
something about big tech,"
they say, "Well, what do you mean?
They're private companies
and we should just leave them alone."
What is your argument against that?
- Well, listen, a monopoly is
a threat to the free market
and also a threat to liberty.
I mean, this is the
problem for those of us
who believe in free market capitalism
is that monopoly stifles competition.
Monopoly raises barriers to
new entrance into the market,
slows down innovation
and of course gives the
holders of the monopoly
incredible power in politics
and we're seeing that now
with these big tech companies.
So I would just say
to those who consider themselves
are defenders of the free market,
to those who considered themselves
defenders of capitalism,
that it is incumbent upon
us to dismantle monopolies
so that the market could function,
we can have more competition,
consumers could have more choice.
Bottom line politically
is our framers understood
monopoly and liberty do not go together
and we've gotta recover
that understanding.
- Do you think, in some sense though
the ship has just kinda sailed here.
I covered all the hearings,
obviously, you were very
involved in all of those.
And when Trump was in
power, there was this idea
that maybe something's gonna happen.
But at this point Biden's in charge,
the Democrats are in charge and it's like,
well, why would they do
anything on this stuff
because it's helping them?
- Yeah, there's no doubt.
I think the Democrats
have really fallen in love
with the monopoly power
of these companies.
And if you listen to those hearings
and cover them as you did,
what do you hear over and over
is the Democrats saying the
companies out of censor more,
they gotta use their
power more aggressively.
I mean, they're no longer worried
about the concentration of power.
They're basically
cheering the companies on
and then threatening to regulate them
if the companies don't get more censorious
which is sort of hard to imagine.
But I do think that the
Democrats, I have really given up
on the monopoly question
because they've come to love it
but that doesn't mean that
the conservatives have to.
I mean, we have to now more than ever
get back to their founders understanding
that monopoly and liberty
are not compatible
and what we need is more competition.
What we need is to
return power and control
to the American people,
that includes control
over your own speech,
control over your own
personal information,
your personal data.
And I think we've gotta be
bold and pushing forward
reforms and legislative
proposals that will do that.
- Why do you think Trump
didn't move on this?
There was this threat of doing something
about Section 230 of
the Communications Act
that we've covered a million times before,
but nothing happened.
What do you think was the hold up there?
- I think that really the White House
didn't get focused on it
and the president, I think,
did not begin to really push it
until it was in an election season
and it was very hard then at that point
to galvanize Congress into action.
But also the real sticking
point was never the White House,
it was always Congress.
And a lot of listen, when
I came to the Senate,
just two years ago, and I
began proposing a to reform
overhaul Section 230 to
break up these monopolies,
I couldn't find very many
takers on my side of the aisle.
I mean, there were very,
very few Republicans
who wanted to be associated
with that or involved with that.
And so I think you just didn't
have a lot of enthusiasm
and that's 'cause
Republican elected officials
were a lot of the times out
of step with their own voters.
Their own voters were saying,
"Wow, these companies have too much power.
They are radical left.
They are censoring speech.
They are shutting down our
speech in the democratic process,
interfering with it."
But you said Republicans who
weren't willing to move on it.
I think that that is changing.
But as you say, the last two, four years
were really a missed opportunity
for Republicans in that respect
and now we've got to
make up for lost time.
And we can do that by being
bold with our thinking,
bold in our proposals, and
to go to the American people
with an agenda to trust bust
here in the 21st century.
- But do you fear that now that
the Democrats are in charge
that if they were to do
anything about all of this
that it would actually just be worse
because you made the point,
they were basically saying,
"Hey, if you guys don't regulate speech,
we're gonna punish you."
I mean, that's basically
what AOC said to Zuckerberg
and he pretty much was like,
"Well, I can't do that,
I'm not God."
But now that they have the power like,
it's hard for me to envision basically
them using that power to expand freedom.
- Yes. I agree with you.
And I think this is one of the reasons
why I'm very, very skeptical
of increasing government
regulation over the companies,
especially the way the Democrats want to.
Democrats wanna further
regulate the speech content
that's on the web and
that's on these platforms.
I mean, that's what they really wanna do
and they wanna tell the companies
that you need to define this as offensive
and you need to find that as threatening
and you need to take down this.
That I think is exactly
the wrong way to go.
We don't need less speech,
we need more speech.
We don't need more political control,
we need less political
control and more freedom
on the internet and everywhere else.
So I think that the way to go
is not to increase the
government involvement
but to break the companies up.
I mean, let's get the free
market involved again.
Let's get some competitors in that space.
Another thing I would say is
let's get people the right
to sue these companies,
these monopolies, if they get deplatformed
and they're treated in bad faith.
It used to be, I mean, it still is true
in every other walk of life
of every other industry
that if a company violates
its contract with you,
you can sue them.
Well, with big tech,
you can't sue them if they
violate their terms of agreement
because the federal
government protects them,
immunizes them, that's Section 230.
I think we ought to withdrawal
that and allow people to sue
if they're treated in bad
faith by these companies,
if these companies violate
their terms of service,
I think that could be a game changer.
- Can you talk about what
actually breaking them up
would look like?
'Cause I've seen a lot of
my more libertarian friends
basically say that is the answer.
Like they've just sort of hit the end,
they got to the end of the road
and it's like, all right,
we don't really like to do this stuff
but I think they're kinda with you,
it's like we have no choice.
What does that actually mean?
So we're gonna break up Twitter,
like what does that really look like?
- Well, here's where I would start.
I would start by making
these companies spin off
all of the various industries
that they've tried to
consolidate under their control.
So for example, Amazon.
Amazon has the dominant
e-commerce platform in the world,
we're all familiar with that.
It also though has a major major share
if not a controlling share
in the cloud, that's AWS.
It also has its own
retail line of products
that it sells on its own platform,
using information from competitors.
They shouldn't be able to do
all of these things at once.
I mean, this is really
what used to be called
a conglomerate merger,
where you have this massive
conglomeration of industries
under one set of hands under one control.
I think we oughta just make
them spin those companies off
by just saying in law
that they can't combine
these different industries
into one giant tech company.
Almost all these tech companies do it.
I mean, Google does the same thing.
Google has the Search, of course,
the dominant search platform in the world.
But Google also owns the advertising,
the digital advertising
sphere at a monopoly level
such that if you want to advertise
anything in the internet,
you've gotta go through Google.
We should make them spin
off those businesses,
sell them off, Facebook,
WhatsApp, Instagram,
they should have to sell those off.
So that when I think about
breaking up big tech,
that's where I would start.
Let's reverse this conglomerate mergers
that big tech has done and performed
by gobbling up all of
these other companies
and let's begin to
reintroduce some competition.
- So you don't think we can send
a couple of government bureaucrats
into the Google offices
to look at the algorithm
and fix that thing.
Is that what you're saying?
- You know, I think that
that's the kind of expertise.
I don't trust the federal
government to do much of anything.
I certainly don't trust them
to try and fine tune these companies.
And I would say that what
that really amounts to
to get serious about it,
is that really amounts
to a form of corporatism.
That's when the government
says to big business,
"You know what, why don't we partner up
and we'll work hand in glove
and we'll work together."
That's what the Democrats want I think.
The Democrats have become cooperators.
They wanna see this alliance
between big business and big government,
they're pursuing in
building that alliance.
I think as conservatives
we should say, "No, no, no.
We reject that whole premise.
We don't want big business
or big government,
we don't want them working
together, we want competition.
We want there to be liberty
and we're gonna pursue
policies that will get that.
- Can you talk a little
bit about what it's like
to be in those meetings?
It's like when you're sitting there
and you're looking at Jack from Twitter,
who looks like he just got off
a three week ayahuasca trip
and you got Zuckerberg who looks
like he was just pulled off
like a synthetic human, like whatever,
like what do you make of these guys?
Like really?
Like, what is that experience like?
Also knowing that the entire world
is watching everything they say,
watching everything you say,
it's all gonna be cut
and edited in crazy ways
and everything else.
- I've actually found
that their appearances
before the committees, for my cases,
the judiciary committee
that they've appeared before
a number of times tend
to be very, shall we say,
unenlightening.
They don't, and you know this, covered it,
commented on it, analyze it,
they say nothing over
and over and over again,
and they try to say nothing
in new and more interesting ways.
And I personally think that those hearings
have a value in putting questions to them
and exposing the fact
that they prevaricate
and obviously and sometimes
just outright lie,
that's the value
but in terms of actually
extracting information,
they really, they don't give you anything.
I mean, there's really little value there.
I will say, I have sat down
personally with Mark Zuckerberg,
I talk about this in the book,
he came to see me in back
in September of 2019,
I believe it was.
I found that meeting much more interesting
because that was a face-to-face meeting
which he was really trying to
change my view about Facebook.
I mean, I think that's
why he came to see me.
This was in Washington in my senate office
and he came to see me and he
really tried to convince me
that Facebook should be
kind of a national champion.
That we needed Facebook
to be big and powerful
in order to take on Communist China.
Then he really went on and on
about this for quite some time
when I turned the subject
to the question of monopoly
he got much less interested
in the conversation.
And he said, "Well, I mean,
we're not a monopoly. We don't."
I said, "Okay, well, if you're not,
if you're not afraid of competition
why don't you sell off
Instagram and WhatsApp?
I mean, you, you, you bought them
so that they wouldn't compete with you.
You didn't, you didn't
start them, you bought them.
Why don't you spin them off?"
And that made him very angry,
he was very offended by that.
He thought that that was
a ridiculous suggestion.
And I said, "Well, 'cause you're
committed to your monopoly.
I mean, you don't want competition.
You wanna be able to
control the whole show."
And that's really the
problem with these companies.
- Do you have some sympathy for these guys
when they're testifying?
Like Zuckerberg there, in that
moment when he kinda said,
"We just can't do all of this stuff."
That's what he said to AOC.
I actually kind of
sympathize with the guy,
I know it's hard to
sympathize with these people,
but at some level they
start these tech companies,
I don't think they're
all evil necessarily.
I think they get lost in their own thing
and it's almost an unwinnable
position in a bizarre sense.
But do you have any sympathy for him?
- You know, I don't tend
to be very sympathetic
when I'm getting lied to.
And I do think that they have
deliberately misled Congress
many times and would do it and will do it
if you'd let them get by with it.
I will say that though,
sometimes depending on
who's questioning them,
you do actually feel a
little bit of sympathy.
And some of the questions
that they have to answer
are really ludicrous and ridiculous.
But on the whole and my view
is these guys are billionaires,
they're not stupid
people as you point out,
these are very capable people,
they didn't get to where
they are by being dumb.
I mean, they're very smart,
they're very accomplished
and they can certainly hold their own.
So I tend not to feel too sorry for them.
I wish they'd be more forthcoming.
I wished they'd be a
little bit more honest.
But at the end of the day,
we can't look to anyone CEO's
personal characteristics
and personal character
traits and hope for the best.
What we've got to do is make decisions
about the structure of our economy.
And when you have monopolies
who are actively suppressed in competition
and actively trying to control
speech, that's a problem.
And it doesn't really matter
who's in charge of the company.
What matters is what they're doing
as a company and their power
and we've got to do something about that.
- Yeah. Do you sense
that also some of this is
that they can use a lot
of linguistic tricks
to get out of all of the legal stuff.
So they'll use phrases like
deboosting or shadow banning
or unbiasing, all of these
things that they mean something
but they mean different
things to different people.
So I've had Jack from
Twitter tweet directly at me
in response to me saying,
"We don't shadow ban."
Well, it's like, we all
know that you shadow ban,
but he may in his up mind just
have a different definition
of what shadow ban is.
So they make up words
so that they're never really
on the hook for anything
- That's right. This
has happened repeatedly.
It was interesting in the
hearing, the last hearing,
where these folks came before
the judiciary committee,
was I think in November of
2020, so just a few months ago.
And shortly before that hearing,
I had had a former employee
of Facebook, a whistleblower,
come to my office and say
that he had information
he wanted to share about
Facebook's censorship practices.
And I tell some of this story in the book.
And one of the things he revealed to me
and reveal to my staff
was the existence of an
internal Facebook platform
called Centra, which allows the company,
it's like a souped up
surveillance platform,
and it allows the company
to track their users
across multiple different platforms,
including across different
usernames and aliases
and attract their posts to
track their internet activity,
to track what they're doing
in different countries
or geolocation.
I mean, it's extraordinary.
And he's shared with us screenshots
of this platform in use
with particular individuals.
That was amazing.
So I get to the hearing and I
asked Zuckerberg about this.
He was clearly very surprised to be asked
but he initially tried to deny it
by very carefully choosing
his words and saying,
"I'm not familiar with any
such tool by that name."
- Plausible deniability.
- Yeah. Wait a minute.
I said, "Sir, are you telling
me that that doesn't exist
or you telling me that you
call it something else?
I mean, what is it you're trying to say?"
Eventually by the way, Facebook admitted
they do have that tool
and it is called Centra.
So he was wrong on all counts,
but he engaged in this
back and forth with me
where he was desperately
trying to thread this needle,
did not outright deny it but
it's suggest I was wrong,
and that's what they do all the time.
- Does anyone go to jail
after any of these things?
I mean, I know not, not Zuckerberg
or Jack Dorsey from Twitter,
but like when they do that
sort of pretty much lie thing,
does anyone ever get punished
for lying to Congress anymore?
Is that a thing?
- Not really. No, not really.
You know, I can remember a
time that a Google executive
testified also before
the judiciary committee
and I was asking him about the tracking
that Google performs
on its Android phones.
And I said that, even if you turn off
the location services on your
phone, it still tracks you.
And he initially outright said to me,
"No, that's not accurate."
I said, "Really?"
And so we started walking
through it and I said,
"I thought that even with
location services off,
the wifi function on your phone
still scanned for other wifi in the area,
still made a note of it,
still stored that information
and still communicated it back to Google."
And then he said, "Oh,
well, yeah, that's true."
I said, "Well, so it's
still tracking you."
At which point he said, "Well,
I wouldn't use the word tracking."
I mean, so there you go.
I mean, where it's this constant game
to get them to be honest with you
sometimes about the most basic stuff.
I mean, I've often think
that these tech folks
when you put them on the stand,
if you say, put them under oath,
if you asked them if the
sun was shining outside,
they would prevaricate.
Oh, well, you know, define sun.
So that's how these hearings go.
- Do you think some of
your involvement of this,
is not only because I
know you actually care
about the constitution and freedom,
and I wanna talk about lockdowns
and a lot more obviously,
but also because you're younger
than the average Senator.
And partly what we have going on here
is a 78 year old president
and I got, I'm here in California,
I got like 106 year old
Senator Dianne Feinstein.
Like we have these old and I'm not even,
I don't mean that to be ages Pelosi,
we have these old,
and even Trump with 74
he would be 75 right now,
if he was president that
baby boomer generation
is just hanging on to power too long
and now there's these new industries
and they don't know how
to react to these things.
- I do think there is a
generational component to this.
I think there's no doubt about it.
And I can tell you,
just from my experience
in questioning on the judiciary committee,
there were multiple times
where I would be asking
a line of questioning
that this is really not
earth shattering stuff.
I mean, this is even
about location services
we were just talking about,
a lot of people know that.
But I was asking some of these questions
and I had older colleagues
who just aren't familiar
with these technologies.
They just don't admit it,
probably do have an iPhone or an Android,
but they don't really use it that much.
They use it to make calls, that's it,
their staff does a lot of the other stuff.
And I had them come up
to me afterwards and say,
"I've never heard that
before, is that true?
I wasn't aware that any
of this was going on
and that's been a pretty common response.
I think that's just generational.
I think that they're not as
familiar with this technology,
and that's one of the
reasons why these hearings,
you've really seen especially,
a couple of years ago,
you could really see the tech executives
tie up members of Congress and knots,
because the initial question
might be pretty doing good
from a Senator Congressman,
but then the response,
they just wouldn't know how to respond.
And the tech CEO or executive
would give a prevaricate response
and then there was no follow-up,
there was no way to untangle that web
that they had just spun.
So I'm glad that it's more
people get focused on this
and spend more time
getting prepped for this.
I think Congress is getting
better at doing oversight.
But to go back to earlier
point, we could talk all we want
about oversight, hearings, lots of talk,
we have to do something.
We can talk all we want
but the time has come to
do something about this
and that's partly what this book is about.
- So we're sort of dancing
around all the topics in the book
but let's talk about the book.
So it's called the "Tyranny of Big Tech"
and ironically the book
almost didn't get published.
Can you explain what happened there?
- Yeah, that's right.
The book was initially
commissioned by Simon & Schuster,
one of the two biggest
publishers, I believe I'm right,
siting in the country.
And Simon & Schuster
naturally has been purchased
by the biggest publisher in the country.
So there you have further
industry consolidation
just like everywhere else,
but Simon & Schuster,
sign the contract for the
book before it was written,
sort of commissioned me in
that sense to write the book.
I wrote it, they saw we're happy with it
and then in January they said,
"Oh, actually you know what,
we're not gonna publish it.
We don't think you should
be able to publish it.
We don't think you
should be able to speak."
And they said that, actually,
they said to me nothing,
they they never reached
out to me personally,
I read this in a press release.
- That's incredible.
So they never reached any
anyone on your team to say,
I mean, just even legally,
you'd think they'd have to
reach out to your lawyer to say,
"Hey, we're severing the
contract or something."
- What they did is that they sent,
I think they made a phone
call, an informal phone call
to the folks, to my agent and said,
"We're gonna to cancel
this," but they didn't send,
they didn't reach out to me.
They didn't send a letter.
They didn't, they didn't.
Then they did a press release.
And he said, "Well, why,
what are you going to say?"
And it's like, well, we'll
be putting out a statement.
And so it was like, well,
I guess we'll read it.
I guess we'll read the
statement, which is what I did.
You know, I read their
statement, which directly
I can't remember the exact words now
but basically said that,
you know what Hawley helped
incite a riot on Capitol Hill,
and you get the impression from that
that I was there at a
criminal riot on the Hill.
Totally false, 100% false
they knew it was false.
And the whole reason they did
it is because they went along
with the woke left mob
that wanted to cancel,
it still does, wants to
cancel conservatives,
wants to cancel Trump supporters,
wants to cancel anybody
who will not bow down
to their woke mentality
and their woke agenda.
And I wouldn't then, and I won't now.
And I'm delighted that
the book had founded
an independent publisher
who had the guts to publish it,
who believes in free speech,
a pretty basic American value,
and now people can read for themselves.
- Let's give Regnery a
little shout out here
because they're the ones
that picked up the book
and they've picked up a couple
other controversial books,
"The Parasitic Mind"
by my friend, Gad Saad,
another one really going after the woke
and they picked him up as well.
What is it that you want people
to mainly take away from this?
I mean, is it just so that they understand
the issues better?
Like, what do you want
the average person to do
after they read this book?
- Well, I want them to
say that first of all,
there's no reason we
have to accept the power
of these tech monopolies, we
don't just have to accept it.
I think that's often what we're told.
This is just how it is.
And if you use these platforms
as overwhelming majorities
of Americans do,
you're just gonna have to get used to
having your data taken from you.
And you're just gonna have
to get used to being spied on
all over the web.
And you're just gonna have to get used to
your children being tracked,
and that's just our economy,
that's how it is.
It's not how it has to be.
It's not at all.
We can do something about that.
These tech companies got big and powerful
with the help of government,
now it's time to cut them down to size
and restore the free market.
So I think that's the message.
I want people to feel
a sense of empowerment
that things can be different
and they will be
different if we demand it.
And also we've got some
control in our own lives.
We need to address this situation
politically and legally.
We need to cut these
companies down to size,
but also personally,
we can do things that
we'll take back control.
We can spend less time on the platforms,
we can take steps that
will limit their ability
to spy on us,
and we can try to get them
out of our children's lives.
And I share about some
of that in the book.
- Yeah. I don't know if you know this,
but I do every August off the grid,
no phone, no computer,
no news, no nothing.
And I honestly think
it's one of the things
that has helped keep me sane
over the last couple of years,
because that news cycle
and that endless scroll,
everyone calls it doom scrolling,
where it's just more and
more and more and more,
it's actually, it's making people crazy.
- It is, it is making people crazy.
And I discussed some of
the data in the book.
What we're seeing,
especially with young people,
we're seeing startling correlation
between increased device
and especially social media
use and depression, isolation
anxiety, and suicide.
It's really, the statistics
are really, really alarming.
And again, it's particular, this is true,
the depression piece of it's
true for people of all ages
but it's really pronounced
among young people
and especially young females, young women
that social media use
and then the correlation
between that and depression
and even suicide is really stark.
And this is something that we
need to get out into the open
and that the tech companies
need to be responsible for it.
They wanna act as if, "Oh my gosh,
they're the model citizens and
their products are all about
making our lives easier and better."
Well, actually their
products are about addiction
and their model is to addict us
and that has major, major
negative consequences.
And so we need to do something about that
and that starts with us personally.
And your example is a great one.
I should see if I could
follow that great example.
But where we say, "Listen, I'm
gonna take back some control
of my own life, and I'm
not gonna live my life
on these platforms day in and day out."
- Yeah. Which everyone is
doing constantly, trust me.
I don't know if as a senator
you can take a month off,
but it is the best thing
that you can possibly do.
I mean, I can actually feel
my brain resetting during it.
It really it's something.
What do you think about
that some of the States
are taking some of this into their hands.
I mean, Ron DeSantis,
who I pretty much think
is the best governor we've got
in this country at this point,
he's basically saying,
"If you deplatform a political
candidate from Florida
we're gonna find you."
I think it was 100 grand
a day or 200 grand a day,
something like that.
Do you think that it can work
sort of at the state level
or does it have to be kind of federal?
- Well, I think ultimately
we will have to do something
at the federal level,
I mean, particularly to
break up the monopolies.
But the States absolutely
to do everything they can.
And I love what governor
DeSantis is doing in Florida.
I think there's some of
our proposal maybe in Texas
and a few other places.
And as I used to be attorney general
of the State of Missouri,
that's what I did before,
I was in the United States Senate.
And in that capacity, I filed
an antitrust investigation,
the first of its kind in the country
against Google and Facebook, both.
So there is absolutely a
role for the States here.
A role for governors, state legislators
and attorneys general to
go after these companies
in every way possible.
And especially now when
you've got the Democrats
really cozying up to big tech,
really falling in love
with their monopoly power
and Democrats in charge
of course in Washington,
we've got to use every
tool at our disposal
to try to hold these companies accountable
and try to give the American
people sort of control back.
And I just I applaud these
States who are doing it.
- Yeah. Let's shift from
big tech a little bit
to just some of the broader stuff.
So because you are a
constitutional conservative,
and it seems to me that the constitution
is under complete assault right now
that the Democrats, whether it's packing,
expanding the courts or getting
rid of the electoral college
or moving on guns or certainly
the free speech stuff
as related to big tech
and everywhere else,
it seems that the constitution
is just being attacked
and I wonder if there are
enough people at this point,
because our education system is so screwy.
If there are just enough people
who will stand up and fight for it,
because they don't even know
what they're fighting for anymore.
- You know, particularly
when it comes to speech,
just to start with that piece of it
it has been remarkable to see,
even in the last five years
the collapse of treasuring
and valuing free speech
among the sort of leading
institutions in this country.
Think about universities,
the institutional press,
the legacy press, these
folks who used to be,
even though they were leftist,
you used to be defenders of
free speech to some degree
and now we're not at all.
In fact, to the contrary,
if they disagree with you,
they want you silenced.
If they disagree with you,
they want you canceled.
So this I think is a
remarkable development
and a really, really dangerous one.
Because if we're not free to speak,
then we can't deliberate.
And if we can't deliberate,
we can't have self-government.
I mean, the whole idea of our Republic
is that the normal people, everyday people
should have control over their lives
and control over their government
and we oughta be making the decisions.
And we make the decisions
because we talked together
and we're were able to converse together.
And if we're not able to do that freely,
if you've got these
companies or the government
interfering and saying,
"No, can't say that,
no, you can't express that view. Nope."
I mean, my gosh, how is
our democracy to go on?
So I do think that we
are at to your point,
as constitutionalist, we're
at a moment of great peril
and we need to be bold and
standing up for the constitution
because you talk in this
moment of division, by the way,
there should be nothing that unites us
like the constitution.
And I think, and the
principles it's based on.
And I think we've gotta be bold
and going out there
and fighting for those.
- How much of that do
you think has to do with
sort of the general collapse of liberalism
that the progressives have just wiped away
any of the old school liberals?
Because even though you're a
Republican and a conservative,
I suspect you probably
enjoyed having debates
with liberals at one time
and now I don't know
where those liberals are.
I used to be one of them.
My whole book is defending liberalism,
except I'm defending something
that seemingly is gone.
- Yeah, I think that's right.
I do think that we think
about the liberal tradition
that this country is part of
the tradition of freedom of speech,
freedom of worship, free government.
That is something that
today's so-called liberals
really have abandoned.
And again, it's happened with such speed.
I mean, even when I was in law school,
which wasn't all that long
ago, a decade or more ago
when I was in college before that,
you could still have
robust debate on campus.
You could have events where
you had a conservative
and you had a liberal,
you had a libertarian,
you had a liberal and they would go at it.
People come and listen.
I wouldn't try to shout down
the conservative viewpoint
but that is increasingly difficult today
on many, many, many American campuses
and it's that same sort of
campus culture that woke leftism
that is spreading into
every sector of our society,
at least into the areas of influence.
It's the leadership class in this country<
the self appointed leadership class
that is really imposing this wokeism
and this cancel culture on
the rest of the country.
- Are you shocked how the
Democrats just kind of folded?
'Cause if you asked me
seven years ago say,
like was Nancy Pelosi truly this radical?
I actually don't think so.
Chuck Schumer, certainly I don't think
was really this radical.
Joe Biden, I mean, I don't
know what he believes anymore
but I don't think, he's
ushering in all of this now.
I mean, are you shocked how
quickly they all folded?
- I'm very surprised
at how hard to the left
they have turned so quickly.
And I think what it
probably tells you is that
for decades now their commitment
to core constitutional
principles has been weakening.
We saw it earlier, I think
with freedom of worship,
that has been one where the
Democrat that used to be
a very bipartisan issue.
It used to be that people would say,
"Hey, religious liberty,
that is a core constitutional conviction
and whatever faith you are of,
or even if you're a
person of no faith at all,
like we should all be able to agree
protect religious Liberty.
The Democrats walked away from
that now 20 plus years ago
and you've seen them do the
same thing with free speech.
I predicted that freedom of the press
they basically have done the same thing.
If you're a conservative outlet,
I mean, that's the
Hunter Biden post story.
I mean, if you're a conservative outlet
no you shouldn't publish.
So it has been their move towards
a form of control oriented
liberalism is really exceptional.
And this wokeism, which
again is basically,
like my way or the high way
either you agree with me
or you're a terrible person
and you should be silenced
and not able to
participate in public life.
- Do you sense more people
are waking up to this?
I mean, obviously you're talking
about it from a political position.
Plenty of people like me talking about it.
I sense there's like some
pushback starting now
but you know, there's
still a lot of people
that are awfully afraid of this thing.
- Well, I think that that
voters, I mean, again,
working people, everyday working people
I think they hate this wokeism.
I think they hate it.
I think they hate being told that
you have to use this
particular set of words,
you can't use that set of words.
And by the way, it changes all the time.
And again, it's the self
appointed leaders of the country
who will tell you what
you can and cannot say.
I think they hate that stuff.
And you know what?
People also hate being told all the time
that they're bigoted,
that they're backward,
that they're racist.
And that's basically
what the Democrat party
and the left says to at least
1/2 this country, maybe more.
Is that since you don't agree with them,
well, that's 'cause you're a racist.
If you believe in the constitution
and are proud of the
history of this country,
you're a bigot.
I mean, if you don't agree
to go along with their agenda
to transform our society,
to cancel women's sports, for instance,
then there's something
deeply wrong with you
and you are a terrible person.
I think people are sick of that.
And this is frankly, one of the reasons,
I think President Trump became president
is because he was willing to
call it out and people said,
"Oh, thank you."
Someone who is willing to
stand up to this nonsense
and I don't think that's changed.
I think even folks who would
identify as being more liberal,
they say, I don't agree with this wokeism
and this effort to
control speech and ideas.
- As I always say,
defending my liberal beliefs
is becoming a conservative position.
It's a very odd time we live in.
Let's shift a little bit
to some of the other things going on here.
So we still I suppose, according
to the infallible Fauci,
we are in inning six of the pandemic.
That's what he told Wolf
Blitzer a couple of days ago.
What should the average
person feel about the pandemic
at this point in the
government response to it?
- Well, I mean, here's the thing,
you hear more and more
people in Washington
complaining about the fact
that there aren't more Americans
who are getting vaccinated.
And part of my response to this is that
if there's not gonna make any difference
to anybody in their daily life,
if you get vaccinated or not
why would somebody go get vaccinated?
Now, listen, a me full disclosure.
I'm vaccinated, I recommend
people get vaccinated
but it's their personal decision, right?
It's a medical decision.
People got to make that
decision for themselves.
And if your message to them then say,
"Yeah, go get this vaccine."
Does that mean that I can
take off my mask? Nope.
Does that mean that I can get together
with the extended family? Nope.
Does that mean go to a
full-scale sporting event? Nope.
They're like, "Well, okay.
Well, what's the point then?"
I just think that you
can't have it all ways.
And they're just this fear-mongering.
I saw this hilarious article,
I think it was in the "New
York Times" not long ago,
where the Times was wondering
why is it that people
are so afraid of COVID-19
and have all of these
irrational fears about it?
And I thought, "I don't
know, why do you think?"
Maybe it's because of your hysterical
irresponsible coverage for
months and months over a year now
where you are not content
to just report the facts
to the American people and inform them
but to really want to control them.
And I think that's what
I hear from folks at home
is they say we just feel like
we're constantly being controlled.
That the government wants to control us,
they wanna control our behavior.
Just give us the facts, tell
us what the real situation is
and then, you know what, we're
pretty reasonable people,
will do the reasonable thing.
But that doesn't seem to be
what the the experts in DC want.
- Do you think it's in some
ways too late to fix that
that the expert class and
the intellectual elite class
they have so either often
been wrong or misled us
or however you want to characterize it,
that I don't think people want
to listen to them anymore.
For example, it's a year
and 1/2 past two weeks
to flatten the curve.
Those first two weeks,
everybody wore masks,
everyone socially distanced,
everyone stayed at home.
We did exactly, everybody,
we did exactly what they wanted us to do.
Now we don't even talk
about that phrase anymore
because it would sort of show
how ridiculous this all was.
- Yeah. And the goalposts
have constantly moved.
I know, I think to your question
it has a leadership class
that ruined his credibility.
Yes, they have.
I mean, this is part of what we see
going on in the country right now
is that everyday normal working people
they don't trust the
leadership of this country.
And that's not just the political leaders,
the elected leaders,
they don't trust people
in the leadership class,
the media, the legacy media,
the press, the leaders of
the major corporations,
they don't trust them because
they think that those people
A live differently than
the rest of the country,
B don't understand the rest of the country
and C wanna control the
rest of the country.
And you know what, they're
pretty much right on A, B and C.
I mean, that's pretty much true.
My view is that you hear all the time,
usually from the experts
about how you know,
the typical American and
the typical American worker
doesn't work hard enough,
isn't well-educated enough,
isn't willing to take the tough jobs.
I don't believe any of that.
I think that's exactly wrong.
The typical American is
the hope of this country.
The problem is with the
leaders of this country,
the problems with the
leadership class in this country
and they are desperately
trying to hold onto their power
while telling everybody else
what they can and cannot say
and can and cannot do with their lives.
I think people are sick of it.
- Where are you guys in
Missouri at right now
in terms of lockdowns and
regulations and all that stuff?
- Well, we never had actually
a statewide masked mandate.
We have a Republican governor and he said,
"Listen, I'm gonna give
the local States and sorry,
the local cities and counties,
the ability to make their own decisions
on masking and so forth.
And I thought that was the right decision.
So we never had a mask mandate
in the State of Missouri.
And now those counties that
did have a mask mandate,
most of those are now gone,
or at least they're significantly relaxed.
And our numbers continue
now to be very, very low
and the vaccine deployment
is going forward,
more and more people are getting it.
So I thought that my state actually
took a very sensible approach to this,
which was give people the
facts, put it out there.
What's the infection rate right now?
What's the total number of cases.
How many people have
recovered and break it down
County by County, let
people see all of that,
let them make their own decisions
and then let local municipalities
make their own decisions.
I thought that was a pretty good move.
- Is part of the problem though
that 1/2 the country
just doesn't see that.
I mean, if you're watching
MSNBC, you are not gonna see
that the numbers are
incredibly low in Florida.
you're not going to see
they're low in Missouri,
they're low in Tennessee
and you're not gonna
see their low in Texas.
So people don't see it.
And then they go, "Oh,
well, that can't be true.
If you can't, you can't see
it, you can't know it's there."
- Yeah, I do think that's a problem.
And this is where the irresponsibility
of much of the legacy media,
the lefty media really,
I think comes into play
the alternative universe
that they have constructed,
particularly these left wing outlets
that they have constructed
is really irresponsible.
It's really, really irresponsible.
And again, what it does is
is that it creates such
a mood of hysteria.
Then the people, they can't get the facts
that they have trouble
making a rational choice
and then ultimately they feel betrayed.
But it turns out that so
much of the hype is wrong
with so much of disinformation
then they say, "Okay, well,
I'm never going to trust
any of these people ever again."
Some cases, I mean, there's,
they're outright falsehoods
that they've told about this pandemic.
I just remember at that point
back in the early spring last year
where we were lectured
and heckled and told
do not wear a mask.
You're, un-American if
you're wearing a mask,
why are you wearing a mask?
People naturally, I remember this in March
I think of last year, people were like,
"Oh, well, maybe I'll get
a mask and wear that."
And the hectoring, no, no,
no, you mustn't wear mask.
And then what basic of just
three or four weeks later,
we were told, "You must wear a mask.
You absolutely must.
It's essentially you do."
I mean, I think people, again are just
they are tired of that.
And it's taken its toll
in the credibility of the people
who are always reporting it,
always forcing it down our throats
and never admitting in the
past when they were wrong.
- And then of course, when
Trump went for a China ban,
that was racist, now Biden has
an India ban, is that racist?
I'm not sure Senator, is that racist?
- Yeah. Well, I haven't
heard a word about it.
I mean, I get apparently it's not.
And MSNBC says it's not, it must not be.
But I was one of the
senators who was urging.
I called for restrictions very
early on to and from China.
And in fact, I may have been
one of the first Senator
to do so, certainly one of the first
and I urge the president
to pursue that ban
and to enact those travel restrictions,
it was absolutely the
right call at the time.
But Oh yeah.
I mean, all the Democrats
were, "This is ridiculous,
it's fear-mongering."
You remember that all it's fear-mongering.
And then they same people a month later,
Trump hasn't done enough,
he didn't never took this seriously.
I mean, it's just if it's
not one thing it's another,
and again this is why they
bear a lot of responsibility,
I think for the inaccuracies
and for the outright falsehoods
in some cases that they perpetrated.
- Yeah. So since you do care
about that old piece of paper
that set up this country, I
thought maybe you could explain,
I talk about it a lot on the show,
but I think you'll be able
to explain it pretty clearly,
the difference, the sort of
guarantee of the constitution
of equality versus what the
left is now pushing on us,
which is equity.
- Well, listen, I mean
the equality guarantee
is that as citizens,
we have the same rights
to stand before the law and to
participate in our democracy
as any other citizen does.
And the country is founded on
this premise and in many ways,
and this is sort of our
core bedrock guarantee
that you don't have to be
born to a certain family
or born in a certain zip code
or have a certain amount of wealth
in order to matter in this country.
And we think that every person matters.
I look back at, Thomas
Jefferson has this great phrase
where he says that cultivators
of the earth, farmers,
are the most valuable to citizens.
Now I come from a farming family
so I heard that a lot growing up
and I tend to agree with it,
but it was revolutionary
statement at Jefferson's time
because if you look back in human history,
people who worked with their
hands were usually dismissed.
And I was like, "Oh, I
mean, that's manual labor.
That's for people who can't get educated
and who aren't smart."
And the idea that manual
laborers would be a citizen
and would have a role in
democracy, I mean, absolutely not.
The Romans for instance, the Greeks,
they would never allow that.
Our country is premised on the idea
that folks who work for
a living are valuable
and that everybody should stand
as an equal before the law.
And it's the law that should rule,
the law made by the people
and not any particular
person or group of people.
So that is a long answer, I guess,
to what I think our core
constitutional commitment is.
And what the left wants though
now is, is identity politics.
I mean, what they wanna say is
is that they want to define
this group, that group,
they wanna put Americans,
they wanna divvy us by race,
they want to divvy us by identities
that they will construct,
that the electoral construct,
they'll tell us which
identities are legitimate
and which not.
And they want to divvy
us up along those lines
and they wanna pit one
group against another.
And that's what they are doing,
that's what a lot of this woke agenda is,
that's what a lot of
this critical race theory
agenda really, and
movement really amounts to.
And that I would submit to
you is severely damaging
to the kind of equality
that the constitution actually guarantees.
- Have you've seen this bill?
I think it's just circulating
in the last little bit,
it has something to do
with the COVID relief bill,
where they are actually
gonna help farmers of color
before they help white farmers.
Have you heard about this?
- Yeah. In fact that's law.
I mean, that's, I mean, that is--
- It is actually the law now?
- It is the law of the land.
Yes. It is the law of the land.
- So what do we do? What do we do?
Systemic racism is here.
- Yeah. I mean, it's here
and the in force, absolutely.
It was in the last COVID relief bill.
And I tell you, this stuff
it's just really extraordinary.
I took a lot of heat for
being the only Republican
in the Senate to vote
no on what was called
the Asian-American hate crime bill,
the Senator Hirono's bill,
this is a few weeks ago.
The reason I voted no
is 'cause it didn't have
anything to do with hate crimes,
those are already illegal.
It gave the department of justice,
the power to define hate incidents,
which is offensive speech.
So it gives the government
the power to decide,
well, this speech is offensive,
that speech is offensive.
And then it gives DOJ
the power to help States
and local governments track it
and monitor it and create a database.
I was like, this is crazy.
I mean, this is a first
amendment problems here.
So I'm against hate crimes,
but I'm not for the government censoring
and defining and tracking
speech for heaven sake.
So at this kind of thing is
becoming more and more common
and we need conservatives
and constitutionalist
to call it out, to stand up
and have the courage of their convictions.
- Do you think the legal system
is the only thing that fixes that,
like to me, that being
a part of the package
as you're saying, that it is law now.
I mean, I actually I just
heard just this morning
that there is a farmer
who is now going to sue.
So I guess I must have in fact,
known that it had been passed
but there a white farmer who's
gonna sue 'cause he is not
by the color of his skin
going to get the same relief
as another farmer because
of the color of their skin.
Is the only recourse really
that it has to get to the courts.
And then basically we have to pray
that the courts do the right thing.
- I think it is now for that
package, once it becomes law,
and I mean then the only
recourse you have left
is to try to go to the courts
and to try to rely on the constitution
and defend your rights.
I'm a constitutional lawyer by trade.
I was a prosecutor in
the State of Missouri,
as attorney general
and so I I'm certainly not
averse to going to the courts
but I will say this, that it
would be much, much better
if we actually stopped these
kinds of destructive policies
from becoming law in the first place.
If we actually stopped the woke agenda
from getting an acted into
law and we need more folks
who are willing to stand up and do that.
And I think right now
there's a real sentiment of
well, we just have to kinda
go along in Washington, DC.
We don't have to go along, it
doesn't have to be like this.
We can present a credible alternative
and we could make the case
for the core principles of our
constitution and we need to.
- Do you think part of this is just that
a certain set of Republicans
kinda want to be liked.
They just, the sort of
Mitt Romney, Liz Cheney,
that battle that's happening now
where it's sort of the media loves
these people that only years ago
they were telling everyone
that Mitt Romney's racist
'cause he was running
against Barack Obama,
but now he's a hero because
he sort of against say Trump,
or you were Ted Cruz, something like that.
The guys who were actually
doing something, but they're,
I keep calling them the PED Republicans
'cause they can get people on MSNBC
to say nice things about them.
- I do think that the
media has really invested,
the legacy media, establishment media,
the leftists are really invested
in this idea of Republican civil war
so they really wanna create
conflict and play it up
between establishment to Republicans
and conservatives are
populous Republicans.
I can just tell you from being home
and with the State of Missouri
and talking to actual people,
I mean, actual voters,
they have no interest
in the Republican civil
war, there is no such thing.
They made up their mind.
They're like, what's the conflict.
They don't wanna go back to open borders
and to ruin this trade policies
and to liberal globalism,
they don't wanna go back to that at all.
So they're like, "What's the
conflict you're talking about?
No, no, no."
They wanna go forward.
They wanna know what we're gonna do
to stop this radical left woke agenda
that President Biden is trying
to force down our throats,
is trying to ramrod through the Senate.
I mean, and then they
wanna know going forward,
what we're going to do to
actually defend our constitution,
to actually get jobs back in this country,
manufacturing back in this country,
and to give working people a voice again,
that's what they wanna know about.
And I think that this media narrative
that you're pointing to, talking about,
it's just, it's false
and it's meant to distract
from where people really are.
- So what should the messaging be?
I mean, I guess that's
sort of what you're saying.
What should the messaging be
for Republicans going forward?
Because I feel like it's still
nobody really knows who's in charge.
Is this Trump's party still?
Is it going some other way?
Like what do you think
that messaging looks like?
- Well, I think we ought
to listen to our voters.
I think what our voters want is
they want us to be a pro worker party
rather than we are for working Americans,
that we are gonna work to get good jobs
that pay good wages for
folks right where they are,
that you shouldn't have to
move to a foreign country
in order to get a good job,
that you shouldn't have to
move halfway around the country
to get a good job.
We need to be the party of working people,
we need to be the party of families.
We need to be out there
fighting for families
to be able to afford to start a family
and to raise a family.
And by the way
to be able to make their own
decisions about their family.
I talk about this in the book,
big tech shouldn't raise our
kids, we should raise our kids.
American families wanna have
the authority and the power
to raise their kids and tell big tech,
"Get out of my life, I wanna
raise my own children."
So I think as a party, who are we?
We're the party of working America.
We're the party of working
families in this country
and we need to be advancing an agenda
that's pro worker and pro family.
I think that is our future as a party.
If it's not, I mean, if
Republicans are not willing
to be the party of working people
and to be the party of working families,
then we're not gonna
have a future as a party.
I mean, it's just that simple.
I mean, that is who our voters are.
And if we're not gonna
be responsive to them
if we're gonna be the
party of Wall street,
or if we're going to be the
party of the globalists,
we're not going to have a party.
- Where does Trump fit into that equation?
- I think that's up to him.
I mean, I think that I don't
know what he wants to do
or will do in 2024 or beyond,
but I think that is entirely up to him.
He's, I can tell you in Missouri,
he still enjoys among Republicans.
Very, very strong support,
because I think people
look at his policies
that we've just been talking about,
they look at it and I say, "Yeah, I agree.
With the direction that he
was taking this country.
I agree with the policy proposals
and vision he was putting forward."
So I think, I think it's entirely
up to him as to what happens next for him.
I'd have no insight into what
decisions plural he will make.
But I think the ball's
in his court on that.
- Sorry, I got one more for you
which is a question I often
get from my audience which is,
are you hopeful?
Do you actually,
'cause we've talked about
some serious stuff here,
I mean, the big tech threat,
the ever expanding government threat,
the wokeism threat
rampaging the institutions.
I mean, this is serious stuff,
but you're in the middle of
the fight, are you hopeful?
- I am hopeful.
I am hopeful and I'll tell you why.
It's because I firmly, firmly believe
that if you go to the
heart of this country
if you go to the working
people of this country,
families of this country
you'll find strength there.
Our people are strong.
Our families are strong, our
working folks are strong,
they're strong in spirit,
they're strong in their
convictions about our constitution
and about our country,
they're not the problem.
The problem is the leadership
class, that's the problem.
If the situation were reversed,
I'd be really worried.
But I think that the great
majority of this country,
the great middle of this country
and I don't mean just
middle geographically,
I mean, the middle of
our society is strong,
that's where the strength is.
That's what we've got to do.
That's why, what we have
to do are advanced policies
that give more opportunity,
that bring more strength
to the middle of our country
and give them a greater voice
because they're the ones
who are gonna be able to
lead this country forward.
And what we've gotta do is
that the leadership class,
which has become
increasingly out of touch,
increasingly corrupt,
we've gotta replace them
and we've gotta give
more power to the middle.
- Well, the book actually got published.
It is called "The Tyranny of Big Tech" .
Senator Josh Hawley, I
appreciate you doing the show.
- Thanks so much for having me.
- Thanks.
If you're looking
(upbeat music)
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right, over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.